this week we've got fun beggin pizza
truck and doggy Armour oh yeah dog armor
fun what's fun banging give me some
butter please stripping oh if it's fun
begging trips if fun begging is like
random fans eating you up because they
want to go on a vacation and they
started a GoFundMe for that I say [ __ ]
you so many themes of people's telling
me hey I made some really bad life
choices and they're young like they look
like they're really young and then
they're like I just started a GoFundMe
because I want to take my girlfriend on
vacation and I can't afford it oh what's
the solos in like if I wanted money I'd
go who's the most Oprah you she's a
billionaire yeah you you watch you watch
our vlogs right like we live it going
like regular life go ask Oprah for
[ __ ] $100 you're [ __ ] me for food
gift cards because they want to eat the
food that I'm eating while watching me
eating it but they can't afford it so
they DM me for a gift cards at
Cheesecake Factory so that they can
watch my video what you didn't shoot
that might be a good deal for the
restaurants if they if they gave you a
bunch of we want to partner with you do
you do you realize what group of people
you're in right now Brando Queen Joe
they just got a McDonald's brand deal
get the [ __ ] out of this room I did it
it was not me I did not okay see by
himself
the one that doesn't talk about it at
all I am so sorry I don't want to rant
but like I always get offered like
[ __ ] like beauty like do I okay
maybe I look like I need it but I could
never get off they don't have that much
money I don't know why but they just
don't my friend is uh he does a lot of
marketing for like food companies unless
it's like major major chains and brands
they don't have that much
I was gonna invite it to a grand opening
a food events thing cuz I have this
friend that does like food things I'll
send her to you okay so this story here
the first story I know your standards
grow they can't afford you that's what
I'm saying all right this story the
first one fun begging it's about the 79
year old woman from China who is very
very wealthy like she's very wealthy
very well-off but she likes to beg how'd
that go [ __ ] for fun mm-hmm you don't
think you can [ __ ] that like the lady
mm-hmm Oh cuz she's very well-off she's
okay that's like Floyd mate you know he
wants to be taken care of but you can't
be with her why cuz she's oh 79 that
mean she's gonna go soon you're gonna
stay with all her money yeah but that
money will keep her around for another
20 years or what if she has kids she
does that kid yeah but the sex isn't
gonna be fun imagine you caress her
shoulder but the skin follows you all
the way down to the elbow you stretch it
favoring it's like why is your shoulder
skin on your forearm dude that was like
you're like trying to take her clothes
you're just dragging all their skin with
it yeah he doesn't want to be taking
care of that okay wait do you guys have
this reminds me of like youtubers love
patreon accounts do you guys a page
everyone quiet I think YouTube channel
and you make a patreon account like you
better be making some freaking movie
quality [ __ ] otherwise like you're
vlogging Hey oh yeah the bloody ones are
a little weird there's a few there's a
few other people that for example like
Wong foo has a page that makes films
funny so that makes sense yeah like
movie I dunno what you're talking about
you have like some of them they just go
they walk around and they just do
nothing and they're like hey can you
support a patreon for you to do nothing
well there's tears right so like for
some I think most people that I follow
if they have a patreon it's like they
have a private podcast or private
there's private content that only
patreon people get hmm
but then I dunno what you're talking
about
like hurt me so I can keep this
full-time for more videos you know when
the other I don't know anyone like that
that's yeah I don't know we don't know
anyway I know it oh [ __ ] about other
surprisingly that's interesting because
there's drama and anything right but
it's just a funny thing to fight over
yeah I or the new bro it's like what
kind of drama do you have yeah what is
it
you stole my [ __ ] camera style what's
mainly like she doesn't eat all her food
there's that or like people think you're
like literally copying like the style of
food that they're doing too close and
then your tacos which are on camera it
all seems like fun and dandy but then
like let's say someone post like a big
shrimp chips video right and it's doing
well and then the next day I'm like ooh
I posted a shrimp chips videos and
people are gonna be like wow that's
every content on you that's not even
like secluded to what you do yeah
everybody does that [ __ ] like literally
things that we have done here have been
ripped so many [ __ ] our friends
decent ones actually ask
I've known seniors that started Fitness
channels it's pretty funny seniors they
just randomly think all the fitness
industry is growing so they just started
doing things
it's pretty funny that's why my mother
said I did three cameras son and [ __ ]
for food places the one who did it was I
was like this is too high quality I
don't want it to do well because he's
gonna raise the standard that's the
problem though because of the weird the
way that I shot it and did it it was so
[ __ ] hard and it wasn't fun so like
you have to watch I'm lighting things
I'm like setting things up I'm setting
up the house I'm eating three cameras
and then I started doing what possum I
got bored of that so I started cooking
and bringing my friends over yeah wait a
min
it let's backtrack a little bit I've yet
to get the invitation so what happened
was we just back do you back I didn't
even know that we have heart-to-hearts
dude by the way I made I made effort and
I asked them to be on the podcast and to
do all this yes and then our video
didn't work because we kept talking baby
the tape so the whole time you hear boom
so we had to scratch that we actually
but I'm not cute videos not at one don't
change the subject job my heart's still
pouring okay
well it's a one-way relationship if he's
just inviting you I made the effort and
I said let's make videos together no
he's not cuz I just said hey I want to
be on that shank he said he said I don't
even know what to cook for you [ __ ]
cuz you guys don't even like food I'm
like I know food anything you make is
hot I can't make candy because that's
just what I was so like he was literally
the last one because I didn't realize
how hard it was alright alright Robin
was ironic I mean Robin from scratch and
that [ __ ] was hard but each of those
things it's like a two-day process yeah
that's a lot of [ __ ] words it's bad I
gotta say though cuz I have to research
it I have to make it beforehand eat it
myself and if it's bad I have to redo it
and then at the bring them on cuz his
because he's cooking it's stupid back to
this all rich lady likes to beg at the
train station here's a photo ever and
now the train station where she bags
they're doing announcements over the PA
system not to give this [ __ ] money
again do not give minors majors rich
yeah like this is her Villa what's do
she has no decency she owns multiple
properties hurt her son her own son came
out and said like yeah we've been
telling her to stop like new
what a hobby but her own image but like
we care about our family image and and
then still a lot of people on social
media they were like well that's so sad
like okay she says she does it because
she doesn't want to be at home and bored
and people are like it a job that's what
everyone is saying like the train
station can just solve this if they
could just give her a job instead of
like let her be the creamy glaze in the
beginning Street the train the train
station they have pride they're like
[ __ ] no we're not gonna tarnish our
image for this lady well in the
beginning was she before she started
begging slanging no she was trying that
dick she was selling maps at the
railroad station but the management
there didn't want her to sell maps so
then that's when she resorted to begging
and another I don't buy her story though
cuz if she doesn't want to be bored at
home then she can get into different
activities she could do things for free
but she's just really greedy and money I
think that's what it is everything she's
parked on every Chinese so bored has no
purpose why doesn't she [ __ ]
volunteer at an orphanage doesn't pay
her money
yeah I think she that likes it I think
it's fun yeah I think so it is fun
that's the thing - so she's saying that
she's trying to get she's trying to make
money for her own retirement which then
people are like wait but you're well-off
already you own a [ __ ] building what
do you need her time because she it's
never enough for people like that anyway
moving on to the next story
so Pizza Hut's they revealed their
tundra truck that they redid to me - so
this thing it wait the Toyota Tundra
yeah yeah so it's fuel done you put the
actual Tundra the bucket ice cold a way
why is pizza oh they did a collaboration
Pizza Hut in Toyota I think she's
explaining it tried to explain yeah
we're all with you let's do it so this
tundra the sienna Tundra they replace a
gas-powered engine with hydrogen fuel
cell electric power unit and they're
gonna display it at SEMA which is the
Specialty Equipment Market Association
show
it's the biggest car show of the country
it's in Bacchus right yeah and so this
whole truck it's good for the
environment and it makes pizzas while
it's on its way to deliver
oh I thought it was powered on pizza no
Howard my hydrogen fuel-cell thing I
know but then when I heard pizza I
collaborated with tundra-like for this
reason Toyota they have the robot in the
back so they're heating that is freshest
but well they're heating up frozen pizza
that still looks good to me
it's not like super like handmade kind
of stuff as long as it has that Pizza
Hut [ __ ] grease crows yeah I'm happy
yeah and then like there's like a robot
and then it boxes them this is like the
truck dad that shell pimp my ride would
make never pizza but you broke we're
gonna hook you up homie we in the past
no this actually makes sense
because their [ __ ] would just like be so
extravagant doesn't even oh you like
fish we turn the compartment into
aquarium yeah thanks pimp my ride
[ __ ] water splashing you back of
their head oh [ __ ] anacondas killing me
in here I kind of just wanted a normal
car yeah it's crazy all these pizza
companies are doing crazy [ __ ] alright
who's the one that's like um repairing
the roads Domino's yeah like they're
doing domi knows dudes all these
marketing marketing things what they're
doing yeah so then people are saying
like man all they gotta do is make this
like a self-driving car and then people
are asked out of a job if this like
really takes off oh come on what the
[ __ ] are you worrying about I cannot
wait till cars just take us everywhere
dude [ __ ] driving man I [ __ ] hate
driving oh it's such a piece of [ __ ] sit
there if I can hold the wheel gotta
[ __ ] open your eyes dude it's so what
I'm looking forward to in the future
it's hopefully they can invent
teleportation because then we don't have
to ever deal with the jerk you'd be down
with the Machine disassembling ourselves
when they perfect the hell yeah I'm down
ha have you watched um see that's why
I'm scared of that dude minds but I know
it's about I am doing I've seen Dexter's
Laboratory do that I want robots to
replace human delivery there's so many
fools that make mistakes cuz half of
them are always high and [ __ ] hmm get it
right it's just pizza
how can you [ __ ] up that some guy was
delivering my chick-fil-a from post
mates and he dropped it in the post
meats bag I don't know why there was no
chick-fil-a bag and he grabbed my fries
with his hands and gave it to me and I
brought it back home
I've logged it and they're like post
mates is finally nice to me now but like
they wouldn't give me a refund for that
cuz I got the food technically it's
amazing like what Twitter can do if you
have a small amount of following dude
like I've even complained for somebody
else once because they were mistreated
by like United care and I just like
retweeted their stuff because like
that's [ __ ] up and then they said that
they got a personal message from them
yeah it's like come on man just do it
just be decent about it you know I got
it so ridiculous
yeah I never try to order fries or
anything that the delivery person can
I'm always like yeah I don't know your
hands a bit what if you want french
fries no 100% though if I was working
for post base that you are the French
fries I'm taking six book exactly
especially if it's crisp cut fries yeah
Juna I'm gonna take the one off the top
yeah and you're not gonna know the damn
[ __ ] difference
I'll just have an extra french fry but
fries are never good we deliver I know a
lot of things that I do we're cool
that's what you think i wink at God I go
and he goes that's exactly what you
should have done yeah you can eat
delivered fries specialist or nasty
exactly see it's like all soggy or I
like what you like soft I like soggy
fries why the [ __ ] do you like soggy
fries I meant to say like [ __ ] cold
get the fat fries from fat burger like
the big yeah I like those those ones
still never got you really good still
yeah well that's really close to her
what's so good about soggy fries I don't
like the crunchiness get the [ __ ] that's
the reason why people like fries I don't
like it
she like soggy fried chicken I don't
like toast that it's like actually brown
like I like it right before it turns
brown like just like slightly you just
never eat food ever just I let's
continue before I start hating you you
want me these are my preference yeah
like potato chips
I can eat without do-do cheese mashed
potatoes did you see citron she just
matches
still raw you think I'm site goes a
little bit yeah I think [ __ ]
it's like bucket barely toasted toast
it's not even told ok he's warm it's
this warm I like it I like it was just
warm let me let me ask you this
chips the most likes are - it's like
it's like you've got a universal rule
for me like I can eat chips after she
steams it shuts the steam I think she
doesn't know herself because the answer
that you have about crunchiness is not
what you don't like about potato of
fries you tell me then the grease more
for the song you like well I don't love
grease but then something about soggy
fries it's like a little bit saltier
than the crunchy wine a little bit more
moist cuz you mean the soaked see you
can articulate whatever go to McDonald's
right and your fries are soggy right
when you get them the reason why it's
like that is because they didn't heat
the oil hot enough and so when you do
that what actually happens in that old
ass grease is so it's sorted in yeah
actually eating [ __ ] old grease yeah
it's like it like McDonald's fries I'll
close the bag so you like steamed up a
little bit and then I knew should be
steaming that [ __ ] I knew you hear she
gave it a sauna
you can't get this on fries please thank
you okay
so terrible I can't take damn it pet
owners are dressing up their small
little pets and be this like body armor
thing to fight against coyotes oh yeah
it's called coyote vest pets body armor
New Year's too late button [ __ ] my Brown
what a [ __ ] benefit from it
I thought of brown so much [ __ ] look
really it's been two years
oh [ __ ] that looks dumb as [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] lethal look all the
spikes you know it's like plastics like
this oh I didn't see that how do you not
see the pink part it looks separate no
he's trying to get the neck
every time I've seen it is always then
this area is unprotected which needs it
the most
you said the underbelly it's not a
turtle girl with a neck because they're
saying that's the first place of it that
is the first place and then they also
have so it's a lot of small dogs in Ohio
they have been taken away by hawks or
they've been oh oh that's why you know I
think I mentioned this story but that's
just so funny because like a friend out
in Texas told me that that's how the
Chihuahua got taken up was that let the
dog out to go pee and then AHA came
gotta grab the Chihuahua I just went off
into what a horrible way there's [ __ ]
Hawks in our neighborhood well I'll look
up and they're just circling for food
yep been getting our meat love love we
love about to get them dude it's too big
I wonder why there's nothing here
well because when they're getting them
it's always from the back or whatever
yeah yeah there'll be Kylie's in my
neighborhood at night there's coyotes
our neighborhoods that's wild cuz your
neighborhood doesn't have a lot of open
land we have a lot of hills though so
all those hills and shrubs that's where
they all chill out oh but I thought they
were houses I was thinking that a lot of
the like the feed dog pose that I was
saying was from the neighborhood is from
the Coyotes there you're like
irresponsible dog owners need to clean
up after [ __ ] yeah you were talking
[ __ ] yeah and so like I was asking some
of the neighbors and they're like no
those are like coyotes there's like
there's like a pack of coyotes I live in
the area they sound so scary
coyotes know these sounds Oh what do
they speak how what night they're not
it's not like being now yeah it's like a
screech sometimes I'll hear like a pack
of coyotes like take down like a cat or
something
and you just hear the animal screaming
for their life yeah that's crazy
yeah it's pretty sick so these vests
range from sixty nine ninety five to
ninety nine nine to five if it's a wolf
dog I won't do anything you guys see
that picture at Joe Rogan posted all
those here huge so it was wolf [ __ ] with
a ton of porcupine quills so that means
that wall here killed that porcupine
still ate and digested that [ __ ]
yeah he ate the whole thing yeah and
it's full of porcupine quills
what's the point of being a porcupine if
all right all those spikes for no
frickin reason he carried it for so many
years I [ __ ] wolf hella hard as [ __ ]
you see all these spikes color
God you made me wrong I got ya
[Music]